[موسيقى]
ارحب بكم من مكان يتالق باضواء واجواء عيد
الميلاد هذا العيد الذي يحتفل به معظم
المسيحيين في الخامس والعشرين من ديسمبر
متى يرتدي اليوم
لكن رموزه وتقاليده لها تاريخ طويل
في هذه الحلقه لحظات هو يرفع الستار اهلا
بكم في اسرار بس
نحن في اكبر متحف في اوروبا مخصصين للحرب
العالميه الاولى
حدث ما لم يكن في الحسبان عشيه الميلادي
عام
1914 على طول الجبهه الغربيه
بين الفرنسيين والبريطانيين والبلجيكيين
من جهه والقوات الالمانيه
في اعز الحرب العالميه
نحن عشيه عيد الميلاد عام
1914 ومن الخنادق ترتفع هذا المسائل
ترانيم عساها ترفع معنويات الجنوب
عندما بدا القتال في اغسطس كان الجميع يظن
ان الحرب لن تعمر حتى اخر السنه لكن
الامال بعوده سريعه الى الديار بددتها
المعطيات على الارض وزخات المطر التي حولت
الخنادق الى بؤر موحله بارده
يوميات صعبه
الامطار فقط كانت تفصل احيانا الاعداء في
الميدان
بين انه منذ ايام حل الصقيع على الجبهه
الغربيه فتدثرت الحقول بلحاف من الثلج وفي
الجانب الالماني تزينت الخنادق باشجار
ميلاد صغيره ارسلها الامبراطور كهدايا الى
جنوده
وسط هذه الاجواء الميلاديه بدات تصلح
حناجر الالماني باغاني العيد فتشجع
البريطانيون في المقلب الاخر وراحوا
يرافقونهم في الغناء
على الجبهات سنخرج جندي الماني من خلف
ستاره الترابي اذا لم تطلقوا النار غدا
فلن نطلق النار
وفي صباح اليوم التالي كان العيد ولم يطلق
احد من النار ثم راحت الرؤوس تعلو فوق
القنادق ولم يطلق احد النار بعدها وقف
الماني يلوح بدراعيه على مرمى من رصاص
العدو ولم يطلق احد النار
خرج الجنود الالمان والبريطانيون الى
العراق
وتبادل الهدايا من علب سجائر وشوكولاته
ومربيه
بعضهم اقتنس الفرصه لدفن من سقط من رفاقه
في المنطقه العازله في ما ارتجل اخرون
مباراه في كره القدم
ويحكى انه خلال تلك الهدنه قال جندي
بريطاني لاخر الماني اليوم يوم سلاما
بيننا لكن غدا تدافع عن بلادك وادافع
مجددا عن بلاده وعلى جبهات اخرى تعدل
فرنسيون الاسلاك الشائكه وتبادل المعايدات
والنكات وقنان شامبانيا حتى النظافه
المانيا من مغني الاوبرا انشد ترانيم
ميلاديه فقبل بتصفيقا حار من الفرنسيه
ولو ان حالات التاخير بين هؤلاء والالمان
كانت نادره باعتبار ان ثلث فرنسا كان
رازحا تحت الاحتلال الالماني
يوم عيد الميلاد سنه
وضاعت الحرب لبرهه قصيره او سارحه لكن مثل
تلك الهدنه لم يتكرر خلال الحرب العالميه
الاولى
طيله السنوات الاربعه اللاحقه القيت
الغازات السامه واشتدت المعارك الداميه
وقضى قرابه 20 مليون مدنيه وعسكري
وكثيرون ممن شاركوا في تلك الهدنه العفويه
رحلوا قبل ان يحتفلوا مجددا لعيد الميلاد
تقليدي عيد الميلاد تسجيل شاشه مخصصه
للمناسبات لكن من اين جاء هذا التقليد
وكيف ولدت وتطورت الزينه عبر العصور قصه
مشجره الميلاد
[موسيقى]
19 يكتشف الاطفال
واقامه شجره الميلاد تقليد يعود الى القرن
السادس عشر ولد في منطقه الالزاس شماله
فرنسا وكانت وقتها منطقه المانيا ففي
الحادي والعشرين من ديسمبر كانت تقطع
اشجار دائمه الخضره لاستقبال العام الجديد
ثم تزين بالتفاح والسكاكر والبرشان واكواز
الصنوبر وفي بعض المدن كان الاولاد يهزون
هذه الاشجار عند انتهاء العيد لتتساقط
منها الاطايب والحلويات مع مرور الوقت
دمى والازهار الورقيه والشرائط البراق
التي اخترعت في مدينه اليوم وعرفت باسم
شعر الملكه
او وسط القرن السابع عشر اضيفت اثنتا عشره
شمعه ترمز الى اشهر السنه
ويحكى انه عندما ضرب البرد موسم التفاح
عام
قام نافع زجاجا باستبدالها بكرات زجاجيه
ما لبست انحلت نهائيا مكان التفاح كاداه
للزينه
الميلاد ظلت حتى منتصف القناه التاسعه عشر
تقليدا محصورا بمنطقه الالزاس والمدن
الالمانيه الى ان حمل النبلاء المان
عاداتي بلادهم الى قصور فرنسا وبريطانيا
والنمسا عندما دخلوها عبر الزواج
فرنسا اقيمت عام
1837 شجره للميلاد في حديقه التلغي بطلب
من الكنه الالمانيه للملكين في ايه
وعم
1871 ضمت الامبراطوريه الالمانيه اراضي
الالزاس واللغان الفرنسيه فنزح الكثير من
ابنائها الى سائر المناطق الفرنسيه ونقلوا
اليها تقاليدهم وفي طليعتها شجره عيد
الميلاد
في صفوف العامه بعد ان كان حكرا على
الانستق
رام ومع اختراع الكهرباء بدا التحول
الاضواء محل الشموع التي غالبا ما كانت
تتسبب بالحرائق هذا الاختراع
ظهر اواخر القرن التاسع عشر في الولايات
المتحده لكنه ظلت عقودا مكلفا جدا في عام
1920 كانت قيمه الحبال الكهربائيه تعادل
ما قيمته اليوم الف دولار وسرعان ما فاضت
هذه الاضواء من اغصان الشجر فتوهجت
المنازل والمتاجر والشوارع بالف نور ونور
ونشرت في عيون الكبار والصغار سحره عين
جميله
[موسيقى]
فضلا عن شجره الميلاد
تقاليد اخرى ترمز لعيد الميلاد نحن الان
في قصر
كل عام باجمل حله استعدادا للعيد معنا
عيد الميلاد
[موسيقى]
اغنيه اسباني
اغنيه فوزي
[موسيقى]
قلوب
بهذا ناتي الى ختامي هذه الحلقه المخصصه
لتاريخ عيد الميلاد على امال ان تبقى
ايامكم كلها ايام فرحا واعياد ودعكم واضرب
لكم موعدا في حلقه جديده من اسرار
[موسيقى]